I'm sure all of you have been told that
you don't have what it takes and that
you may not be good enough and you don't
have enough people supporting you and
you're being told all of these things
when deep down it's all you want to do
you want to be a part of something great
you want to make something great and it
does more than knock the wind out of you
it crushes you when people try to tell
you that you're not good enough and it
almost did for me but there was my mom
next to me stronger than ever and she
said the most important thing is to
always trust in myself if I'm doing
something because I love it I should do
it because I love it and I believe I can
do it